[Music]
on this Thursday night tragedy on Ice a
deadly incident in Ottawa when a group
of teens fall into the icy R River I
know what these parents are going
through it's really difficult why
conditions on the river have been
particularly dangerous this
winter the last missing Canadian from
hamas's Attack confirmed dead my mom was
shot in her arm shot in her face the
fate of Judy Weinstein as Israel's
Relentless Siege on Gaza
intensifies plus icons and Trailblazers
remembering some of the influential
individuals who left us in
2023 global national with Donna freezen
reporting tonight Colleen Christie good
evening thanks for joining us we begin
tonight with a tragedy this holiday
season a teenage boy is dead and another
is missing after four teens fell through
the ice on ottawa's RTO River last night
as Abigail Bean tells us it adds to a
growing list of ice related accidents as
warmer than normal temperatures cause
dangerous conditions on our lakes and
rivers two young women light a candle
and look on in tears as police search
the R River an SUV sits blocked off by
police tape nearby what looks like boots
a shirt and a cap four teens fell
through the ice Wednesday night one boy
and a girl got themselves out taken to
hospital with mild hypothermia during a
search in difficult conditions that saw
a police diver hurt in serious but
stable condition police found another
teen boy's body the search for the third
boy continued Thursday we lost an oldest
son uh 7 years ago he was 36 and he was
uh killed in a motorcycle accident so I
know what these parents are going
through it's really difficult so for me
it it kind of like I feel extra bad for
the parents it's really sad Terry perto
lives nearby and walks this path every
day and says while there's very little
ice and fastr running water now was
solid just the other day not only have
temperatures been warmer than usual so
far this winter they've also fluctuated
above and below zero that affects how
the ice freezes experts call it dirty
ice and say it's both unsafe and
unpredictable very likely to crack or
break under any sort of pressure the
only real way to tell if the ice is
thick enough for a person or a vehicle
is to use an augur the life saving
society says 35% of drownings happened
between October and may Ottawa is just
the latest Tuesday the body of a
61-year-old Calgary man was pulled from
the boow River Police believe that the
victim was taking a photo of something
and when he fell for the ice also
Tuesday the three bodies of the pelma
family were found after their off-road
vehicle went through the ice west of
Edmonton they had been been reported
missing when they didn't show up for an
event Christmas Day and north of Quebec
City Friday a 4-year-old fell into the
river while sledding with her mom the
search continues and with winter staying
warmer overall for much of the country
because of an El Nino pattern in place
we're looking at milder than average
temperatures experts urge everyone to be
careful around any water even if the ice
looks solid Abigail ban global news
Ottawa the military says 10 people have
been rescued in the Northwest
Territories after a small aircraft
crashed near a diamond mine about 300 km
Northeast of Yellow Knife officials say
the aircraft operated by air Tindy went
down Wednesday afternoon eight were
injured but are said to be showing signs
of improvement the Royal Canadian Air
Force helped parachute rescue Personnel
to the site last night with helicopters
brought in this morning to move people
out after nearly 3 months of uncertainty
Judy Weinstein Huggy the only Canadian
citizen still missing following hamas's
October 7th attack on Israel has been
confirmed dead the 70-year-old was
believed to have been taken hostage in
Gaza but today her family confirmed she
was killed on the day of the attacks
regie Chini now with reaction to her
death and the Urgent calls for Action as
danger for hostages and civilians
increases in
Gaza this was one of the final moments
of a routine life for Judy Weinstein a
morning walk around kabut only hours
later this 70-year-old mother of four
and grandmother of seven would become
one of 1200 others who died as Hamas
militants stormed Southern Israel her
daughter telling Global News weeks after
her suspected abduction by Hamas of the
horror her mother endured that day my
mom was shot in her arm shot in her face
her last words can be heard pleading
with paramedics for help her death was
announced Thursday online by the Kuts
she lived in she was a US Canadian
Israeli a former teacher turned poet and
wellness facilitator and a wife of GTI
hagay also a victim of this attack US
President Joe Biden saying in a
statement that the families had been
living through hell for weeks and no
family should have to endure such an
ordeal we're all mourning
today the bodies still lie with Hamas
who has yet to release a statement but
has noted time is running out every day
that goes by is a day too long that
they've been held uh by Hamas in the
tunnels under
Gaza with so many hostage whereabouts
unknown the public outrage at the
Israeli government is unrelenting with
calls for it to do more than just
respond with military
power which to now shows no sign of
letting
up Thursday brought fresh air strikes to
the south of Gaza the same region
residents were told to escape to for
safety this woman screams in a desperate
attempt to find her family in this
overburdened
Hospital the pain is also being felt in
the occupied West Bank where the United
Nations is decrying recent raids and
violence noting an ongoing deterioration
of Human Rights the use of unnecessary
or disproportionate Force by the Israeli
security forces are extremely
troubling even as Israel promises this
to be a long and intense campaign a rare
moment of Contrition from the IDF after
a December 24th strike injured and
killed children in Gaza the unintended
consequences of a conflict with a
growing toll Reggie Chini Global News
Washington the United States has
approved a $250 million military
assistance package for Ukraine in what
could be the last funding available
without new approval from Congress
president zalinsky thanked the White
House today for supplies he says will
cover Ukraine's most pressing needs air
defense ammunition and anti-tank weapons
are all being delivered from existing
Pentagon stocks the move bypasses the
need for Congressional approval after us
lawmakers defeated an emergency spending
measure that would have provided
billions to keev earlier this month and
in the US Maine's top election official
has now blocked former president Donald
Trump from the 2024 US presidential
primary election ballot the decision by
main Secretary of State ruled Trump was
constitutionally ineligible for inciting
Insurrection to due to his attempts to
overturn the results of the 2020
election the decision is sure to be
appealed it follows a similar decision
made by Colorado's Supreme Court last
week for the same reasons the nation's
High Court could resolve for all states
whether Trump can run again the push to
Snuff out smoking coming up the new
pressure on Ottawa for a lifetime ban on
cigarett
sales
with the hope of creating a smoke free
generation Health experts are calling on
Ottawa to adopt a lifetime ban on
cigarette sales to anyone born after
2008 a similar policy is being
backtracked in New Zealand but as Nara
reports that hasn't stopped other
countries including the UK from
proposing similar
restrictions Health experts are urging
Canada to get even tougher on tobacco
tobacco Remains the leading preventable
cause of disease and death in Canada
right now 12% of Canadians smoke that's
far too high espe Rob Cunningham with
the Canadian Cancer Society says they've
long supported the proposal now before
Ottawa to implement a ban on cigarette
sales to anyone born after 2008 and rais
the federal minimum age for purchase of
tobacco to 21 a tobacco free generation
proposal shouldn't be the only thing
that we do you know we need to have
higher tobacco taxes we need to have
fewer retail outlets uh selling tobacco
products to ban all remaining promotion
of tobacco companies Cunningham
highlights Federal statistics that an
estimated 46,000 Canadians die from
tobacco use each year and it causes 30%
of all cancer deaths he says the ban
should include vaping products
increasingly used by Youth and supports
the country's Target of less than 5%
tobacco use by
20135 but critics call the idea a major
policy overreach it's unworkable um and
it's not really going to achieve what
people hope it's going to achieve Brock
University Professor Dan Malik believes
the proposed ban is like prohibition
with a history of failure and is likely
to strengthen illegal networks of sales
in the midst of a toxic drug crisis if
we go down this road of banning tobacco
to certain people it's going to add to
that crisis under Britain's proposed
legislation anyone 14 or older will
never be able to leave legally buy
cigarettes or any other tobacco product
New Zealand plans to scrap its policy
believed to have inspired the UK and
Canada Health Canada told Global News an
analysis of data collected including
from public consultations is underway
adding its considering measures being
looked at or adopted in other
jurisdictions Nea Global News
Vancouver still ahead the newest names
to receive Canada's highest
honor
[Music]
governor general Mary Simon has
announced 78 new appointees to the Order
of Canada one of the country's highest
civilian honors the list includes former
much music and CBC host George stromal
opoulos as well as Wilton littlechild a
former Creed Chief and Truth and
Reconciliation commissioner he played a
key role in bringing Pope Francis to
Canada in 2022 where the pontiff
apologized for the harm residential
schools caused Francine lamir a gold
medalist at the 1988 par Olympics and
former president and CEO of the College
of family physicians of Canada is also
among the
recipients Canadian basketball star
sheay gilgas Alexander has been named
2023 is Canadian press male athlete of
the Year both teams crashing offensive
glass the three Shay gilis
Alexander the 25 old from Hamilton LED
Canada to its first ever medal at the
feo World Cup and its first spot at the
Olympics since 2000 he also became the
first Canadian since Steve Nash to make
the all NBA first
team next paying tribute to some of the
exceptional people we lost this
[Music]
year few of us expect to leave a last
Las in impact on our communities let
alone the world but many have done just
that whether through service sport or
entertainment those whose work was
extraordinary leave behind an inspiring
Legacy for generations to come a look
back now at is some of the prominent
people we said goodbye to in
2023 If You Could Read My Mind love what
a tell my thoughts could
tell just like an old movie about a
ghost from a wish I love the work and I
love it so much it it has to radiate
itself somehow it has to make that
connection there was a time in this Fair
land when the railroad did not
run when the wild Majestic mountains
stood alone against the
Sun that I will Faithfully execute and
then Along Came Jimmy Carter and my
life's been an adventure ever
[Music]
since it just shows that when we work
together we can attain great success for
the economic engine of Canada that a
woman can do anything a man can
do as to this um uh serious question of
insulin I thought we were the party of
the John de Baker Bill of Rights I
thought that's who we
[Music]
are I said just Canada's greatest
National Treasure is our parliamentary
system of
[Music]
democracy we have to come to grips in
America
with our love affair with
[Music]
weapons yes back then I uh used humor as
a defense mechanism thank God I don't do
that
anymore it was just funny all the way
through all 237
[Music]
episodes do you think it'd be fun if we
got married I never wanted to be away
from
her when the going gets rough and I can
make it going to make our dreams come
true doing it our
way
guys like us we had it
made those were the
days don't you think Jamie would look
good in
[Music]
that oh look at that an alert I'm
probably trending
[Music]
already
If I Were a Rich
[Music]
Man all day
long if I were a we
[Applause]
man
love means never having to say you're
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry
[Music]
if one only remembers to turn on the
light
[Music]
George Reed regarded as the outstanding
fullback in the Canadian Football
[Music]
League
he was the face of hockey in the 60s
Here Comes Hall in a shot he
scored and I knew how we were changing
the game just by the way we were
[Music]
playing
this is Jim Brown the most devastating
ball carrier in the history of
[Music]
football you must try to IGN that it
means
more you put the on
me I Left My
[Music]
Heart in San
Francisco Nothing
Compares nothing compares to you
[Music]
yeah we pretty Queen New York
City
[Music]
s
been all right than you
tonight than sweet as
[Music]
wine searching for my
Sher R drops keep folding on my
head and just like the guys is Fe to Big
for his bed nothing seems to fit don't
you ever ask them why if they told you
you would cry so just look at them
and and know they love
[Applause]
you sometimes I think it's a s and I
feel like I'm with and man I'm losing
[Music]
again before we leave you tonight
there's one more person we'd like to pay
tribute to she was one of our own
doriana temo who helped launched global
national in 2001 died in November from
breast cancer at 64 on top of the work
she did for this newscast before
retiring in 2016 as news director she
was already a longtime trailblazing
journalist on air and in the field she
began her career in the late 1970s
working for decades as a respected
reporter and anchor she will be greatly
missed thanks for watching have a good
[Music]
night